they call them caravans their groups men
and women charging to the center of the
pro-democracy demonstrations in central
cartoon they come from across the city
and from outside as well a week after
the fall of dictator Omar al-bashir this
revolution against him and the military
men who are still in power hasn't lost
any of its momentum they had called for
a million to take to the streets over
the day they could have achieved that
their resolve to see the revolution
through knows no gender or class
everyone has focused on achieving
democracy whatever it takes
there's still so much to do you don't
know where to start because this has
been going on for three thirty years and
to undo whatever that was done is going
to take a long time and a lot of support
and everyone has been coming together
and everyone has to understand that it's
not one person's job but it's everyone
together to come up with the same spirit
the same attitude that is here now with
this sense of peacefulness and
the point is that while the military
council has locked up by sharing some of
his family not much else has changed the
people's representatives negotiating
those changes have told Sky News they're
waiting for an imminent reply to their
proposals we're not doing any such is
the fear that what has been achieved so
far could so easily be lost ensures that
thousands upon thousands turn up to the
demonstrations throughout the day as
well as the night and it's blisteringly
hot they work shifts to keep the
barricades man despite those fears there
is a real party atmosphere as well
military personnel joining the crowds in
song and dance clap Don as they lead the
chorus
[Music]
that's not something you expect to see
this in the military shutting and amidst
the crowd singing songs because military
haven't gone it's not over by any means
but I never thought I'd see this in
Sudan
[Music]
across the world in other countries
fighting dictators Sudan is proving to
be a model of a revolution they would
love to copy many have died here of
course but these people believe they won
well almost
mr. Roger Sky News cutting